when I was in high school I remember I
was the first time I was like thought I
was going to have sex you know
and listen I don't know about you guys
but in high school we had sex outside
there wasn't a lot of inside available
you know what I mean so we did a lot of
outside sex you know
right and so I remember bringing a
blanket because I was classy and
I I take her out and we're in the woods
and and so my brother had I had three
older brothers so I was getting drinks
since I was 14 years old and right and
so I had my brother she loved this stuff
I see some people around my age she
loved this stuff called Purple Passion
which came in a can
you know it dude the rumor wasn't had
ever clear in it so [ __ ] people up but
she loved it she was like give me a four
pack of that I'm like you got it
and I I think I was drinking some wine
coolers I'm [ __ ] ridiculous like that
so we're we're fighting so
yeah yeah I drank a zemer too man yeah
that's right yeah you know I did
so
yo and by the way I say to her I go I'm
like hey she's like we're gonna have
some sex tonight I go yeah we have sex
tonight yeah
and we're in the woods and uh we're both
pretty drunk and I go to kind of
reposition myself because we're gonna
have sex and I'm drunk and I and I I put
my hand on her stomach and I guess I
press the button
she threw up right in my face
but guys not like a her like a back
you know like when it hits your like
when it like it was hitting my like like
a hose not only that she [ __ ] herself
also at the same time
but you know what's great about being a
teenager not a deal breaker
oh no don't worry do you want to shower
and then
she's like no I want to go home I go no
damn but do you want to shower first and
like see if something maybe
she was like yeah but I I have [ __ ] on
myself I'm like yeah but you won't in a
couple minutes
she was not she was not she was like no
I'm going home I'm like okay
[Music]
that's how big her titties were they
made that noise through the air